these are in it was nothing short of a
love fest from the media over
president biden's first news conference
the press boasting about biden's
performance
and claiming the only reason why he
wasn't asked about topics like kovid
is because he's doing such a great job
the biggest news arguably was in his
opening statement
quite a contrast to the previous
president who always wanted to be the
center of attention
you actually heard somebody that was
trying to bring americans together a
confident and emboldened president today
there is a sense
of humanity that he is talking about
here saying this is who we are this is
the america that we are
we have to give him time give him a
break i think that as he goes forward
they'll be asking tougher questions
there wasn't a single question on it
there's clearly not any negative
questions to ask
kova is going well right now for him
biden only took questions from 10
reporters and was apparently too scared
to take
a single one from fox check out what
happened when peter ducey confronted the
white house
after being shut out of the so-called
news conference
fox is the only member of the five
network
tv pool that has never been
on the list in front of the president
and i'm just curious but that is
official administration policy yes but
has the president taken questions from
you since you came in
since you he came into office
unfortunately yes or no only when i have
shouted after he goes through his whole
list i'm always happy to have this
conversation with you even about your
awesome socks you're having on today you
wearing today
all right greg so the media and the
biden administration collaborated
to produce a phenomenal press conference
for the democrats and joe biden
and then they all give themselves a big
round of applause afterwards for how
great the press conference was
is that about right i want to hear more
about the socks
don't you what was he wearing yeah
that's where the story
jen sacks knows where the story is by
the way to your point i
just occurred to me that joe is in fact
controlling the border he built a wall
to keep journalists out
which is pretty impressive the media
reminds me
of my dad when i played little league my
head was never in the game and so my pop
was always thrilled i didn't humiliate
myself
and that's the media the media their
parents at a little league game
and i heard uh yamiche alcindor actually
brought an ice chest
of orange slices to the press conference
yesterday
but the secret service wouldn't let him
bring it in uh yesterday i said cnn
didn't your parents bring orange slices
to games
or was it just mine yes all right anyway
yes
yes you got to keep the blood sugar up
yeah okay uh
wait wait wait wait wait wait okay
i have come to the conclusion that news
anchors
are now uh becoming our parents
instead of expressing objectivity they
express disapproval
and pride instead of that okay so
there's always this i'm so disappointed
in you face
over at cnn john berman brienne keeler
don lemon
it's like america is some toddler that
can't tie its own shoes
i call it the resting cnn face it's a
mix of chronic disappointment and
constipation
i knew you were going to get
constipation in there somewhere it's
friday all right katie pavlich
to me it just appeared that the media
spent half the press conference
encouraging buying to nuke the
filibuster and then the other
half of the press conference pretending
to really care about getting access to
the border and then accepting the
blackout
well look the questions in terms of
coming from the left and
encouraging activism like nuking the
filibuster
that's not surprising only seven percent
of the white house press corps
identifies as conservative or republican
but i think it's time that the white
house correspondents association stand
up for peter ducey and say why is it
that there seems to be this blackout
when fox news is part of the pool
they're one of five cameras it's time
for them to say
you know we want equal treatment for
people who are doing the work
inside of the white house and the other
thing that they're not talking about and
this is something that
people on the right have been noticing
and not allowed to talk about because
it's joe biden he's a democrat but
he he lost his train of thought multiple
times yesterday and i just can't imagine
that if any other
president who wasn't a republic a
democrat if that would be the kind of
treatment that he got
just ignoring it and brushing under the
rug that he stopped mid-sentence
he lost his train of thought he looked
confused at times
and wasn't able to answer a number of
questions and so
and also the room was very limited due
to what they say are covered
restrictions so he didn't even have to
face the full
bore of the press corps yesterday for
his first press conference
and juani had a lot of help he brought a
bunch of notes out with him
referred to his notes throughout the
press conference couldn't remember basic
facts and figures there we have some
notes right there
at one point he was just straight
reading a statement that was written for
him about north korea i found that
pretty alarming and then
he had some pictures next to the names
of the reporters so he could remember
who to call on very very well scripted
event juan wouldn't you say
i think that's what you want to do i
mean to my mind by the way as a former
white house correspondent for many years
i can tell you not everybody gets called
on i don't think the new york times got
a question yesterday is what i've heard
but if this is a pattern if they are
excluding fox that's a problem
and you want to make sure that that
doesn't go on too long because i think
that doesn't serve the president's
interest
especially as he talks about unifying
the country but i
you know but in large response to your
general point jesse i think
you're angry at the media because
they're reporting what you don't want to
hear i think biden did very well he
certainly exceeded all the low bars of
slow old show great mood
oh yeah this is not oh the the press
didn't do its job in fact
biden did very well and the press
accurately reported
no big gaffes well into your opinion
commanding in his presentation no i'm
just telling you
i'm going to say that yes sir when you
said to
yeah hey look uh jesse am i talking to
jesse waters you lose your train of
thought on the show sometimes come on
i'm just telling you the press hasn't
ever been at a loss for words
no i didn't say that i didn't say that i
agree on that point
but i think to criticize people for you
know accurately reporting that he had a
good day you know look
he just he just blew up your narrative
that he was incompetent
in fact he did pretty
he had a good day what does that tell
you oh he had a good day
that's what you say about someone who
isn't well i thought he would have a bad
day yes
in general gramps
ronald reagan used to say oh he had a
good day
but you know what he did have a good day
you're saying it in a very
patronizing way again that's your
opinion no i'm not all right shannon uh
peter ducey i do agree with juan if it
does become a pattern
it is going to be a situation but the
guy only holds a press conference every
what
10 years so these these press
conferences matter
well and and two if he's going to keep
talking about unity juan mentioned this
there's a very mixed message there
because
he talked yesterday about the fact that
i'll work with any republican who wants
to work with me and then he sort of
dunked on the fact that the 2 trillion
covid bill was passed without a single
republican we find out he's not talked
with
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
but ron clayne is holding meetings
with the squad and with the progressives
so you know it questions whether or not
he's all about bipartisanship which he
talked about in the campaign
but he doesn't seem to be about now and
maybe he doesn't have to to get past
what he wants to pass or to sign an
executive order